[Applause]
what the democratic convention
lacked in the usual theater crowds and
balloon drops
it perhaps made up for in familiar faces
welcome to the 2020 democratic national
convention
this was michelle obama's fourth
convention speech
and nearly four years since leaving the
white house
it appeared just as personal for her
when my husband left office
with joe biden at his side we had a
record-breaking
stretch of job creation we'd secured the
right
to health care for 20 million people
four years later the state of this
nation
is very different more than 150
000 people have died and our economy is
in shambles because
of a virus that this president
downplayed for too long
michelle obama endorsed joe biden but
missed the chance to speak
personally about his running mate her
speech
recorded before kamala harris became the
first black woman
to run on the presidential tickets for
the two main parties
an early flaw in the virtual convention
but the finely tuned lineup of speakers
was designed to appeal to a broad
electorate
from twice presidential hopeful bernie
sanders
during this president's term the
unthinkable
has become normal to former republicans
the convention cast a wide net across a
splintered electorate
i'm a lifelong republican but that
attachment holds second place to my
responsibility to my country
that's why i've chosen to appear at this
convention
instead of crowds in the host city
milwaukee
a digital hub is orchestrating online
events around the country
by contrast donald trump is touring
battleground states
as debate rages in washington over his
attacks on the postal service
ahead of an election where millions of
people plan to vote by mail
the only way we're going to lose this
election
is if the election is rigged to remember
that
it's the only way we're going to lose
this election so we have to be very
careful
it's unclear how big an audience this
virtual convention will draw
in the midst of a pandemic with the
country in a state of crisis
people may tune in for far more than
political entertainment
sally lockwood sky news